vamos con el problema 59 problemas 59
dice que un agente de bienes raíces
recibió una comisión del 6% del 6% sobre
la venta de cierta casa cuál fue el
precio de venta de la casa entonces
queremos saber el precio de venta precio
de venta a ese precio de venta de hummer
llamarle ve vamos a ver qué opciones
tenemos de información en la 1 nos dicen
que el precio de venta el precio de
venta menos la comisión de la gente
menos 0.06 ve estoy aquí es la comisión
verdad del 6 por ciento del precio de
venta es igual es igual a 84 mil 600
todo esto de aquí son dólares sale a 84
mil 600 bueno pues aquí claramente
podemos determinar ve aquí tenemos una
ecuación lineal en vez de las de primero
de las de primero de secundaria que
podemos resolver fácilmente en el examen
de simat no tendríamos que hacerlo pero
ahorita lo voy a hacer para que veas que
es sencillo aquí haciendo la resta nos
quedaría 0.94 b en 94 b es igual a 84
mil 84 1600 y entonces b sería igual a
84 mil s 8 quedó bien feo sería igual a
84 1600 dividido entre 0.94 y eso cuánto
es déjame sacar la calculadora es 84 mil
600 dividido entre 0.94 90 mil eso de
ahí sería igual a 90 mil ahorita lo
hicimos porque tenemos mucho tiempo pero
en el examen de james pues no no no
podemos darnos esos lujos sale bueno
entonces hasta ahorita la opción 1 es
suficiente por sí misma vamos a ver qué
pasa con opción 2 nos dice que el precio
de venta de la casa o sea de fue igual a
250 por ciento o sea a 2.5 veces el
precio original de compra de 36 mil el
precio original de compra de 36 mil o
sea
podemos multiplicar por 36.000 pues aquí
también claramente se puede determinar
el valor de verdad me parece que una vez
más es 90000 porque multiplicar por 2.5
es lo mismo que multiplicar por 10 y
dividir entre 4 así que si me parece que
nos da aquí 90 mil 90.000 de esta forma
cada una de las opciones por sí misma es
suficiente para encontrar el valor de b
y por lo tanto la respuesta es de sale
de muy bien vamos al siguiente problema
al problema 60 el problema 60 nos dice
que raíz de equis entre y entre y es
igual a n y lo que queremos hacer es
determinar el valor de x muy bien en el
inciso 1 nos dicen que el producto n es
igual a 10
ah pues esto está fantástico verdad aquí
podemos pasar la llave multiplicando o
sea multiplicar por 10 de ambos lados
tenemos que raíz de x es igual n de esta
forma a raíz de x es igual a 10
conociendo esta información y por lo
tanto x es igual a 100 x es igual a 100
entonces hasta ahorita la opción 1 por
sí misma es suficiente y lo que nos dice
la opción 2 es que que es igual a 40 y
que 'en es igual a un cuarto en es igual
a un cuarto pues esto tiene todavía más
información que el inciso 1 verdad aquí
sabemos el valor de idn por separado y
esto lo podemos multiplicar nos quedaría
que lleguen es igual a 10 y una vez más
tenemos que raíz de x es igual a gené
que es igual a 10 y por lo tanto x es
igual a 100 ojo no es menos 100 porque
aunque aquí hay una raíz al elevar al
cuadrado si nos queda siempre positivo
entonces con esto determinamos que x es
positivo y por lo tanto x es igual a 100
sale si fuéramos al revés tendríamos que
tener cuidado con los signos pero aquí
pues no hubo ningún problema bueno
entonces le pongo palos
y de nuevo la respuesta es de problemas
problemas 61 el problema 61 nos pregunta
creo que voy a necesitar más espacio nos
pregunta determinar cuántos enteros hay
entre pero no incluyendo a los enteros
rs entonces le voy a poner enteros
/
/ pero no incluyendo digamos
estrictamente entre r y s y nos dicen
además que r y s son enteros r y s r y s
enteros
muy bien bueno en la opción 1 lo que nos
proponen es que ese menú cr ese menú cr
es igual a 10 es igual a 10 esto de aquí
será suficiente pues déjame meditarlo un
poco digamos que sucede qué sucede si s
es igual a 11 y r es igual a 1
entonces los enteros son 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 y 11 y queremos cuántos hay entre 1
y 11 pero sin incluir los extremos
entonces serían los 11 números menos
estos dos serían aquí 9 números 9
números y en realidad pues no es tan
importante que ese sea uno y ese sea 11
si eres cualquier otra cosa digamos
cierre de 23 entonces ahora ese sería
pues cuántos serían esos 33 si verdad
sería 33 y simplemente estamos
recorriendo este intervalo pues cierta
cantidad de lugares y la cantidad de
enteros entre estos dos sigue siendo la
misma siguen siendo 9 entonces el inciso
1 es suficiente
para responder la pregunta que serían
nueve números y el inciso dos nos dice
nos dice que hay
hay nueve enteros
/
pero no incluyendo r1 y ese asunto ese
asunto ok entonces mira que nos están
diciendo aquí nos están diciendo la
cantidad de enteros en el intervalo
recorrido en uno por ejemplo se hace
aquí está el intervalo r ese entonces el
intervalo r
r 1 s 1 es simplemente este mismo
intervalo pero recorrido y lo que sucede
es que agarramos a ese 1 pero ahora pues
ya no tenemos a r entonces aumentó en 1
la cantidad de enteros verdad entonces
realmente o sea los enteros que están
aquí son los mismos que los enteros que
están aquí en cantidad y simplemente
estamos recorriendo un intervalo 1 al
este intervalo para acá es más uno y del
otro lado es menos 1 entonces hay la
misma cantidad de enteros entre r 1 y
ese más 1 que entre reyes entonces saber
lo del inciso 2 también nos da la
respuesta y otra vez tenemos como
respuesta de vale bueno ahora vamos al
problema 62 problemas 62 el problema 62
dice lo siguiente nos dice que nos
pregunta cuál es el número de miembros
del club x que tienen al menos 35 años
ok entonces vamos a ponerle
al número de miembros miembros del club
x con
mayor o igual que 35 años
años y lo que nos piden determinar es el
valor de y vamos a ver qué información
nos dan en el inciso 1 del inciso 1 nos
dicen que exactamente tres cuartas
partes de los miembros del club x tienen
menos de 35 años ok entonces le voy a
poner así 33 cuartas partes del total
total tienen menos de 35 menos de 35 ok
entonces una cuarta parte del total
total tiene
mayor o igual que 35 años años pero esto
todavía no es suficiente para determinar
el valor de g queremos el número no el
porcentaje de miembros que tienen mayor
o igual a 35 años entonces aquí nos dan
el porcentaje vamos a ver si podemos
combinar esta información con la del
inciso 2 para conseguir la cantidad de
miembros que tienen más de 35 años
entonces en el inciso 2 nos dicen que 64
chicas chicas ok bueno nos dicen que 64
chicas chicas de x constituyen el 40%
constituyen
el 40 por ciento de los miembros totales
de x aunque y eso está muy bueno verdad
entonces tenemos que 64 64 es igual a
0.4 el total el total de miembros de x
entonces de aquí pudiéramos despejar el
total de miembros de x el total total es
igual a 64 dividido entre 0.4 y teniendo
la cantidad total de miembros sabemos
que una cuarta parte de ellos tiene
mayor o igual que 35 años juntando está
bueno o sea el inciso 2 por sí mismo no
es suficiente pero juntando lo con el
inciso 1 ahora sí tendríamos que una
cuarta parte de este número sería la
cantidad de miembros con 35 años o más
entonces los de 35 los de mayor o igual
que 35 años sería igual a un cuarto por
64 entre 0.4 y con esto ya podemos
determinar el valor en realidad ahorita
pues no nos importa determinarlo sino
simplemente saber que podemos hacerlo
vale bueno entonces tenemos que juntar
ambas socios
para poder responder y entonces aquí la
respuesta de este inciso sería c
necesitamos ambas porque ninguna por sí
misma es suficiente